seigneur nous vous rendons grâce de nous
rassembler autour de cette table nous
mettrons de la joie et dans chaque pièce
ab
j'ai fait monter des jouets dans sa
chambre j'espère qu'il se plaira ici
et qui sont ces étranges personnages
avec leurs capuches j'en sais rien elle
m'a rien dit
la demeure que vous habitez a été bâtie
sur des ruines de quoi parlez vous vous
entendez des choses la nuit c'est à
propos des voix
qu'elle rit-il monsieur leloup trois
heures quelle heure est-il monsieur
leloup une heure
quel rythme
a dit
hadi
et
cette pièce alors lt internet mais c'est
quelque chose de bizarre cette maison
dressent les enfants entre leurs parents
les maris contre leurs femmes pouvez
vous m'aider
dieu vous a vendu votre fille il peut
aussi vous la reprendre
quand les ténèbres se rapprocheront et
qu'à part la peur le ressentir
saurez-vous encore qui vous êtes
pourquoi dieu de l'ertms il l'existence
du mal
[Musique]